the man leading the FBI's investigation
into Hillary Clinton's use of a personal
email server and Russian interference in
the 2016 election testified before
Congress this week agent Peter struck
the personification of the righteous
left thinking they know better than the
rest of us was a composite of pompous
arrogant indignant sarcastic smug
condescending defiant
and unapologetic struck seems to share
Cardinal Covey's affectation about being
a selfless servant of the people even
though he seems to simultaneously hold
us all in contempt struck is also the
personification of the deep state itself
where fascism rules where people in
power don't care what you think but
instead decide they know better they
know what's right and then they
implemented but no worries struck isn't
biased he says so himself
after months of investigations there's
simply no evidence of bias in my
professional actions for me it was one
of the most stunning don't believe your
lying eyes moments I've ever seen his
own text exchanges betray his denial he
and his mistress Lisa page called Donald
Trump an effing idiot loathesome a bigot
an enormous D blank blank blank awful
abysmal a disaster the irony here is
that if you want to show bias you would
simply use his words and for any of you
who still don't believe you're lying
ears take a listen to this commit 10
days before the investigation began
which the department you work for says
nothing was done before July 31st you
said Trump is a disaster I have no idea
how destabilizing his presidency would
be between July 31st and August 8th how
many interviews
did you conduct related to the alleged
collusion between Russia and the Trump
campaign I'm asking for a number haven't
gotten to the names how many people had
you investigated you interview that
counsel of the FBI based on the special
counsels equities have directed me not
to answer any questions about the
ongoing investigation into Russian
attempts to any voters so he's directed
not to answer any questions by counsel
for the FBI so why is this important why
would it be important to show the
investigation began before the FBI said
it did why because nothing happened to
even begin an investigation they made up
a date and they made up a reason the
Democrats in Congress knew the danger
zone they were in and desperately tried
to use every excuse to end the questions
and so pandemonium broke out in the
House of Representatives he has said
that he's been instructed by the FBI not
to answer the question
pulled point of order mr. chairman your
Chairman mr. chairman is it not
appropriate to also interject the
attorney-client privilege which cannot
be overridden and is a rule of the house
to have the right to an attorney client
privilege in this house mr. and that is
what this witness is asserting that's
Turney cried privileges and he has been
archives not as to answer the girl a
little suspend and it went downhill from
there the free-for-all in that hearing
room was a sight to behold
but more than that it was a microcosm of
what the left has done when they want to
shut down the right the pent up rage and
the pandemonium was an example of how
angry the left is and while the
Republicans conducted themselves
in a genteel manner the Democrats
claiming parliamentary points of order
blew their collective gasket so struck
arrogantly claims he's following FBI
protocol they told him not to say
anything but six hours later he's shown
yet again to be a liar and is allowed to
answer the question that goes to the
heart of the basis for this absurd
investigation into Donald Trump's
alleged connection with Russia and when
given the green light
here's strux answer Haeju struck between
July 31st 2016 and August 6 2016 how
many witness interviews did you conduct
as part of the Russia Trump campaign
alleged collusion investigation I don't
recall and I'd have to check the case
file we waited all that time for that
answer yes sir
that's eerily similar to what you said a
couple hours ago and if that isn't
enough the tax quote I want to believe
the path you threw out for consideration
in Andy's office that there's no way he
gets elected but I'm afraid we can't
take that risk it's like an insurance
policy in the unlikely event you die
before you're 40 so struck wasn't trying
to prevent Trump from winning what he
was doing was even worse he was talking
about having a plan to effectively
disenfranchised the voters who elected
Trump should Trump win forget democracy
forget the people those voters whom
struck doesn't like are idiots he said
so himself in a text to his mistress if
his candidate of choice didn't win the
one he helped avoid criminal liability
he was going to abuse the power we
entrusted him to ensure that it didn't
matter if the unthinkable were to
his insurance policy would help deal
with it the insurance policy my friends
is the Russia collusion investigation
and that's why I wrote the book Liars
leakers and liberals detailing the power
structure trying to bring the president
down the book hit store shelves on
Tuesday but you can still pre-order it
right now on amazon and
barnesandnoble.com and don't forget to
tell me what you think on my Facebook
page and what you think of the open